alright so a lot of you have asked me
for an update on the subjects and now
here it is alright so the second annual
you reviewers Movie Awards it's coming
it's gonna be awesome for those of you
who don't know what the you reviewers
Movie Awards is okay so last year the
guys from schmoes know contacted me and
they were like all right there's a whole
YouTube community of moviegoers movie
fans movie reviewers let's do our own
movie award show yeah we review movies
for God's sakes let's make an award show
it'll be awesome so we did it last year
we got positive feedback from you guys
thank you so much for liking it loving
it watching it and so full circle it's a
year later and we're like all right
let's do this again well then let's make
it bigger and better than last year so
we got some cool stuff coming to you
guys this year and if you remember last
year we got some celebrities too katee
sackhoff was in it she said my name
Jeremy John she said Jeremy my name John
it was awesome so beyond fanboying out
right here Katie's on board for this
year also and we're trying to get more
celebrities in the mix too you know we
want to make this the biggest award show
we can for you guys why because what we
do we do for you guys we love you guys
you guys are awesome despite what your
douchebag public school teacher tells
you you do deserve it and this involves
a lot of YouTube movie reviewers hence
you YouTube and you reviewers the
schmoes myself chris stuckmann Katherine
Reitman Grace Randolph from beyond the
trailer and many more sounds like a
total TV trailer this person this person
that person had many more it is what it
is many more when's it gonna air we're
thinking a week or two before the Oscars
so around the middle of februari no
other things we have in the mix for you
I can't tell you everything which is
that's kind of cool it's a good sign
that things are getting bigger when I'm
sworn to secrecy but things are in the
mix and I think it's going to be cool
and thank you for liking my star wars
review thank you for appreciating the
fact that I am taken on the original and
only Star Wars trilogy the original
annotation in that video said I was
going to do the next one empire strikes
back on monday i'm actually pushing it
to tuesday says tuesday now because on
monday well there's another you
reviewers movie award video may or may
not be the nominations in the categories
just saying and i've been really
surprised at how many of you guys are
making videos about the you reviewers
movie awards 2012 thank you for that if
you type in you reviewers movie awards
2012 videos that people have made about
it you guys rock you're awesome I love
seeing that if you guys have an opinion
on the you reviewers Movie Awards make a
video about it but it has a video
response to this video I love seeing
that because some of you out there
have opinions I know you've felt it your
opinion cannot be contained by 500
characters in the comment section now
video time baby so keep an eye out this
monday for the nominations in the
categories and if you haven't subscribed
to schmoes know yet check them out
they're a big part of the you reviewers
Movie Awards without the schmoes there
would be no you reviewers Movie Awards I
just be spending all my time playing old
Republican you know be content so thank
you all for the support thank you all
for the love you guys rock second annual
your reviewers movie awards coming to
you guys from me and the schmoes and as
always if you like what you've seen here
and you want to see more click right
here to see more